[Música]
/ de que río de la plata' solemos hacer
eventos con un montón de gente vamos a
algún lugar grande y un montón de gente
está durante todo un día escuchando
charlas espectaculares con ideas
transformadoras pero ahora estamos una
situación del mundo muy especial un
mundo que en poquito
poquito tiempo cambio mucho y no podemos
hacer un evento y hay temas urgentes que
queremos conversar tampoco tenemos el
tiempo de preparar una charla cortita
bien condensada como siempre con lo cual
vamos a hacer un formato nuevo para tx
río de la plata' que es una conversación
con alguien que sabe mucho sobre todo de
este tema de el coronavirus de las
pandemias hoy voy a tener el lujo de
conversar con fernando polack que está
aquí fer es médico es infectólogo es
experto en enfermedades respiratorias
trabaja en eso hace más de 30 años y
dirige la fundación infant y le voy a
preguntar qué está pasando y qué tenemos
que hacer
bien bien muy bien y quiero quiero
empezar con una pregunta grande lista
que de vez en cuando en la historia de
la humanidad
hay cambios profundos extensos que
suceden en todo el mundo un poquito
tiempo no sucede muchas veces pero de
vez en cuando sucede y parece que
estamos en uno de esos cambios si vos
miras cómo era el mundo hace tan sólo
unas semanas pareciera que hoy estamos
viviendo en un mundo totalmente distinto
y que está pasando si yo siento lo mismo
que sentimos yo creo que es así creo que
es la primera vez a pesar de que la
gripe pandémica fue como una práctica de
esto de una práctica que tenía también
algunas consecuencias más severas que
esto esta es la primera vez que
realmente se siente la sensación esta se
siente la sensación buena de una
pandemia de una situación en la que todo
el mundo está envuelto donde creo que
queda el salvador uruguay y mongolia sin
casos
es donde uno siente que todo el mundo en
todos lados está viviendo en un
incertidumbre muy particular
empecemos por lo más básico de entender
cómo es esto que de repente todos nos
enfermamos con algo esto lo llamamos
epidemias o pandemias de acuerdo al
alcance en qué consiste y cómo funciona
en realidad nosotros todos nos
enfermamos con algo todos los años todo
el tiempo y lo que hace distinto esto en
el caso de coronavirus 19 es que nos
enfermamos con algo con lo que nunca nos
habíamos enfermado antes en general
cuando nos enfermamos de algo que jamás
había entrado al ser humano como es este
específico coronavirus porque otros
coronavirus tenemos una y otra vez
sucede que algún animalito a veces
salvaje a veces nos salvaje modifica un
poco un virus y nos lo pasa a los
humanos y los humanos sabemos poco que
hacer con estas cosas nuevas hasta que
las aprendemos y el tránsito a aprender
a controlar las enfermedades nuevas es
lo que se llama pandemia una enfermedad
diseminada por todo el mundo con poco
control cuando decide aprender te
referís a que nuestro cuerpo desarrolle
la inmunología para estar defendido o es
más un aprendizaje social de cómo evitar
que esto se propague jan extravagante es
buenísima yo no lo había pensado
pero lo viejo es aprender la inmunidad
para defenderse y lo nuevo lo que es
nuevo esta vez es que hay un aprendizaje
social completamente distinto a otras
veces para que esto no se propague y que
yo creo que va a tener consecuencias
para la próxima vez que suceda se
escuchan varios términos algo técnicos
de cómo funcionan las pandemias que
están empezando a llegar al público en
general como lr0 y como cuán contagiosa
es una enfermedad y cuánto es la
severidad de una enfermedad como con
contaros un poquito cómo es la dinámica
que hace que esta pandemia nos esté
preocupando más que otras bueno pues voy
a tratar de lo desde un panorama digamos
más general y lo vamos a ir acomodando
esta pandemia está esta pandemia es una
pandemia que la característica más
importante es la extensión de la
infección la creencia más importante es
que hay muchísimos infectados en el
mundo y eso es malo porque permite que
cualquiera se infecte y es bueno porque
indica que la mortalidad no es tan alta
como se dice
si vos tenés y desinfectados y un muerto
tiene 10% mortalidad si tenés mil
infectados y un muerto que es una muerte
de cada 1000 y estás en una situación en
la que si vos contra es la enfermedad
estás mejor
que se hace para saber cuánto problema
va a presentar un un germen en
general son estos virus hay un número
que se hizo famoso llamada recelo del
que nadie hablaba antes que es la
cantidad de sujetos que una persona
infectada a las que le puede transmitir
la infección no la enfermedad la
infección que lo puede contagiar al
gérmenes son muy contagiosos como el
sarampión de sarampión tiene una reserva
de 1616 quiere decir que cada persona
infectada en promedio infecta a otras 16
exactamente y hay otro germen que son
poco contagiosos por ejemplo una gripe
común contagia pero en 1 en 2 es la
cantidad de personas que infectan porque
es importante esto es importante por las
medidas de salud pública que uno tiene
que hacer para contener esa infección si
una vacuna la mitad de la población
contra el sarampión el sarampión con ese
ere cero de 16 con esa capacidad de
infectar 16 personas se muere de risa e
infecta a toda la otra mitad para
contenidos ahora tiene que tener
protegido al más o menos el 95% de la
población la gripe como tiene menos
capacidad de infectar se frena antes
con que uno tenga el 70% de la población
inmune a la gripe a gripe deja circular
no encuentra por donde pasar este es un
germen que es bastante hábil pero que
evidentemente también tiene un ere 0 y
en ese sentido van las medidas de
contención la medida de contención van
para limitar la cantidad de susceptibles
es decir de personas que aún no se han
infectado porque el que se infecta ha
desarrollado defensas entonces el que no
se infectó cuanto se encuentran con cada
infectado y se sabe cuánto es el resero
de esta pandemia de esta enfermedad los
cálculos iniciales hablaban entre 2 y 3
yo tiendo a creer que es más grande que
este virus tiene capacidad infectar más
gente que 2 y 3 pero es muy probable que
el éxito de china que china ha contenido
a esta pandemia se debe básicamente a
dos factores hay un tercero que se hizo
muy popular que al que yo le creo poco
que es el cambio de temperatura porque
en china entre enero y marzo cambiaron
dos grados la temperatura
pero realmente el gobierno chino fue
evidentemente eficaz en agrupar a la
gente en las casas en no permitir que la
gente esté permanentemente en contacto
con lo cual disminuyó la exposición de
susceptibles y el virus círculo lo
suficiente para que los muchos de los
susceptibles que somos todos en realidad
se infectan entonces vos creas una doble
barrera una barrera porque el la nueva
persona infectada no se encuentra con
nadie entonces no lo puede pasar y
porque con los que se encuentras las
infectaron antes entonces el virus se
encuentra su límite hay varias cosas que
quiero de seguro es este recelo que es
el promedio de gente que cada infectado
contagia se me ocurre que depende de dos
cosas una es la dinámica del contagio si
es por el aire si es por tocarse si es
por intercambio de algún tipo de fluido
o ese es el primer factor y el segundo
es un factor social de cuánta gente
tenemos cerca cada día si pero el que
ello es cómo se comporta después se le
reserva la red es un número absolutos y
donde estés digamos obviamente si vas te
metes y a mí de la cancha y te empiezas
a abrazar con todo el mundo vas a hacer
un problema
pero en general un buen ejemplo es dos
bacterias la salmonela era llegue la no
voy a hablar de la reservo pero creo que
esto se ve entender vos necesitás
alrededor de 100 mil copias de salmonela
para tener una gastroenteritis una
guerra pero con 10 de gisela tenés
problemas entonces eso es la dosis cuál
es la dosis que te saque la enferma
entonces este germen es muy hábil para
una vez que entra sarampión por ejemplo
propagarse alcanzar otra persona quedar
flotando en el aire encontrarla en el
camino entonces vos tenés que restringir
desde ese lugar tenés que tomar esta
medida de contención social para evitar
en el caso el coronavirus que no es el
sarampión pero es un germen infeccioso
la oportunidad el germen de ir
desplegándose de hecho yo lo que te
diría que este germen tiene dos
problemas importantes y quizás el
principal de los problemas que tiene
este germen es que tiene una incubación
muy larga es decir cuando uno se infecta
está en promedio 6 días pero hasta 14
días en desarrollarse sin síntomas que
es exactamente entonces está infectado y
no sabe bueno no sabe si las autoridades
sanitarias tampoco
entonces cuando uno está mirando la foto
de hoy de buenos aires hoy estamos creo
que es 13 de marzo 13 de marzo verdad y
estamos mirando la foto de alrededor del
6 de marzo que es el día que se
infectaron los que están siendo ya el
hospital todo lo que pasó el 7 8 9 10 11
y 12 ya pasó y nos vamos a ir enterando
aunque hoy nosotros pusiéramos a todos
los seres humanos en una burbuja los
infectados de los días anteriores van a
ir apareciendo entonces lo que nos
tenemos que saber es que primero que el
invierno soy esta idea de que el
invierno el vernos hoy y la segunda idea
es que tenemos que parar porque no
sabemos dónde estamos sabemos dónde
estábamos pero también de mucho cuidado
con eso cuando existen hemos que parar
es tenemos que tomar medidas en realidad
para sí
absolutamente eso impacta en la segunda
pregunta qué es la severidad de
mortalidad genera que también hubo
discusión respecto a los porcentajes es
decir si uno se contrae el virus cuál es
la probabilidad de que uno muera la
probabilidad de que uno muere es menor a
la que dicen yo nadie la sabe pero yo
especulo que debe ser más o menos uno
y sería parecido a la gripe como sé lo
que pasa es que gripe común todos los
años tiene el 10% de la población
mundial más o menos y acá tenemos la
oportunidad tener todos coronarios
entonces en números absolutos uno ve
diez veces más gente siendo el hospital
diez veces más gente muerta pero es
porque todos hacemos lo que hacíamos a
lo largo de diez años y además porque
sabemos que se llama distinto
porque este no es el primer evento en el
mundo que sucedió ahora tiene nombres y
ciertas características y eso nos genera
el problema la otra parte de la pregunta
que me haces tiene que ver con lo que
veníamos hablando antes en términos de
la susceptibilidad de bueno en la calle
y todo lo que los gobiernos intentan no
es parar la infección pararse delante de
los vidrios con las manos y evitar que
entre pero hay una decisión estratégica
si uno quiere una catarata en la cabeza
no quiero una gota durante más tiempo la
gota permite que el personal de salud se
ocupe de atender a los más enfermos pero
también prestar la atención al resto
tiene un cierto control de dónde van
apareciendo casos para tomar decisiones
la catarata
la catarata en wuhan y ahí es mucho peor
porque el problema ya no es solamente el
virus sino que es el sistema de salud
claro esto es lo que también en las
discusiones en estos días se dio por
llamar aplanar la curva exactamente que
esencialmente lo que dice es si vos vas
si hay va a haber un millón de personas
que se infectan en una zona hay dos
formas de hacerlo uno es sin ningún tipo
de medidas con lo cual se van infectar
todos muy rápido pues un virus que se
transmite rápidamente o puedes poner
medidas como la cuarentena o evitar
ciertos contactos evitar cancelar
conciertos actividades públicas
proponerle a la gente que tome ciertas
medidas y entonces demorar el contagio
de ese millón de personas con lo cual al
final se contagia en la misma cantidad
pero nunca cuando logras aplanarla nunca
que saturar la capacidad del sistema de
salud porque el problema de hacerlo
pronto si te entiendo bien es que al
saturarse la salud se van a morir no
tanto podría la enfermedad sino que no
tuvieron atención estas enfermedades
tienen una singularidad
que es que muestran las grietas del
sistema de salud como cuando uno renueva
parte de su casa y ve la parte que nos
renovó mis oficinas a mi casa está
bastante bien pintadas un par de paredes
miras el varios sitios no por tener este
baño lo tengo que cambiar eso hacen
estas enfermedades entonces uno dice
bueno mi sistema de salud está bastante
bien y de repente te das cuenta que te
faltan gente para atender respiradores
que no tiene suficientemente entrenados
ciertos sectores que le está pasando
italia que no tenéis aquí además
obviamente los ig más alumnos se piensan
para pandemias entonces como haces para
dar respuesta a un huracán cuando vos
siempre estabas en una brisa no acá hice
un poquito de investigación fue mirando
para atrás a lo largo de la historia y
según encontré hubo a lo largo de los
siglos
muchas de estas pandemias que mataron
entre 25 y 40 por ciento de la población
de la zona que afectó de entre 25 y 40
por ciento eso sería visión o sea miles
de millones de personas muertos ahora
entre ellas una en el año 430 antes de
cristo que se llamó la plaga de atenas
que parece que fue el comienzo la
decadencia de
atenas en el 540 1 después de cristo
empezó la peste bubónica y también mató
una cantidad impresionante de gente
después en el siglo 14 la peste negra y
después siglo 19 y primera mitad del 20
el cólera
todos esos mataron una fracción
importante de la cantidad de gente que
está viva y después está la gripe
española en 1918 que también no fue
pandemia a nivel global pero tuvo un
impacto gigante donde mató más gente que
la segunda que la pendencia la primera
guerra mundial claro que era más o menos
en esa misma s porque por parte de lo
que combinó las cosas no los ejércitos
juntos y que ahora aprendimos algo de
todo eso como para que esta vez sea
distinto así que yo creo que sí yo creo
que sí yo creo que se vio en la pandemia
de gripe del 2009 cuando el virus de la
pandemia de gripe del 2009 es
extremadamente parecido al virus del 18
muy parecida mismo a 16 la estructura
del virus digamos yo no mirar a la
estructura viral son tan parecidos que
toda persona que había estado viva
cuando circuló el virus del 18 y eso
quiere decir las personas que están
estuvieron tan vivas que nacieron entre
el 18 y el 57 o antes del 18 y llegan
antes porque porque todo ese tiempo
círculo
mismo virus después todos los años
entonces toda la gente que tenía memoria
de ese virus
cuando llegó el virus del 2009 no se
enfermó yo tenía en esa época mi abuela
vivió tenía 95 96 años está fenómeno
podría haber ido a bailar a una
discoteca que sería inmune totalmente
inmune a la gente más protegida entonces
los virus eran iguales sin embargo en
uno se murió más población que la
argentina y en el otro se murió una
cancha de fútbol entonces nada bueno
pero comparativamente y por qué porque
teníamos antibióticos porque teníamos
antivirales porque hubo el desarrollo de
vacunas muy rápido porque la gente se lo
tomó en serio una campaña agresiva de
control y bueno todo eso en el mundo
entero y sequedad hizo que las cosas
salgan mucho mejor ahora te digo una
cosa para dar un panorama de hoy nadie
sabía que iba a ser mejor cuando fue la
primera el primer año de la gripe
pandémica la expectativa es que el
segundo año 2010-2011 las cosas iban a
ser peores que en el 1er
y cuando nosotros hicimos un estudio en
el 2009 y vimos lo que había pasado
repetimos el estudio al año siguiente y
prácticamente no había enfermos y eso
permitió no solamente aliviarnos sino
que muchas instituciones que estaban
preparadas para dar respuesta a esto en
el hemisferio norte donde venía después
la pandemia aprendieron de nosotros que
lo que nosotros les ofrecerá para
aprender de ellos y dijeron pucha este
año va a ser tranquilo y pudieron
reubicar los recursos para hacer las
cosas en forma inteligente tan genial
esos son las pandemias son las las
pandemias más viejas más históricas pero
hay cómo empezaste a mencionarla en las
más nuevas 2002-2003 la del sars el 2009
el h1n1 que era la gripe porcina después
tuvo el ébola también tuvimos antes de
eso el lazio y todas esas son pandemias
más modernas que también tuvieron
impacto grande no comparable a los
anteriores o sea el el sida mató a
decenas de millones de personas 71
impactó con pero entre el sars y n1h1
son mil personas cada uno más o menos el
h1n1 mató 100.000 más o menos
muchos años del primer año porque la
madre no viene el áfrica ya no se sueco
el ébola el ébola es como si fuera un
incendio forestal que emana el lugar la
gente que se enferma de bola no llega a
otro lugar entonces por eso luego la no
se generaliza es interesante o sea es
ese es un caso de una enfermedad
extremadamente agresiva que por lo tanto
no contagia tan lejos con la gente no
llega a viajar de morir la peor
combinación sería una bola con la
incubación de coronavirus clave que sea
contagioso mientras escobas exactamente
inclusive si eso sería terrible
un genio del malaria pero inclusive si
no lo fuese tendrías tiempo que un
montón de gente se te reubique y el día
que explota te genere como nichos de
enfermedad alrededor de ellos
la verdad que de bola por eso nunca
nunca pasa de la región donde está si de
fue distinto del sida enfrentó otro tipo
de prejuicios otro tipo de no nos
encontramos en una época donde no se
habla de educación sexual donde había
una homofobia inmensa en las poblaciones
ronald reagan se toma siete años para
decir la palabra sida dijo que desde que
se aparecen los casos de 1.081 eeuu el
nombre ha sido por finales en mil 987
1984 es una referencia a la enfermedad
por primera vez de hecho había toda una
visión de es un problema de ciertos
grupos el primer término con el que se
nombraba el cid era gay cáncer entonces
esto fue un cambio rotundo en la
población de otro tipo la comunidad la
comunidad gay se empezó a organizar
empezó a desaparecer como problema agudo
todos los días nuevos casos y empezó a
aparecer en comunidades heterosexuales
que mostraban que evidentemente el
problema iba hacia otros lados por
ejemplo los drogadictos endovenosos
en un principio golpeó mucho a los
hemofílicos que la gente que necesitaba
productos de la sangre que nadie sabía
que está vencida entonces empezaron a
generarse grupos de familiares de
pacientes y pacientes organizados que en
un concepto que no estaba y empezó a ver
un montón de temas de educación sexual
se empezó a hablar de un montón de el
profiláctico perfil activa con ser los
abuelos en ese método como de model
bueno obviamente eso cambió por completo
eso impacta a otras enfermedades
transmisión sexual pero el precio que se
pagó por esa transición fue inmenso
inmenso entonces bueno ojalá nunca pase
una cosa así de nuevo ahora por un lado
fer y estoy tratando de entender
emocionalmente dónde estoy con esto a
veces porque por un lado decís hay que
tomar medidas urgentes para que esto no
se propague pero por otro lado los
números que tiras de severidad y de
contagio no son tan alarmantes como
algunas de estas del pasado no eso es
verdad y la verdad es que esta es una
enfermedad como yo decía de números
absolutos sino en números relativos el
problema es
la sobre afluencia de gente a los
servicios médicos y que al que le toca
le toca y a la gente que le toca
falsamente se cree que le toca solamente
por edad y no le toca solamente por edad
y por enfermedades nadie bueno si uno
tiene un problema pulmonar ahí se tiene
probar pero si no tiene 85 años si no
tiene ningún problema son lo mismo que
un chico de 20 no lo sos y no lo sos
porque este virus tiene un
comportamiento muy inusual y es el
siguiente esto es sentido como puro si
un virus se infectara porque es agresivo
tres grupos que seguro estarían
afectados son los chicos las embarazadas
y los inmunosuprimidos ninguno de los
grupos está afectado con el corona no
hay grandes datos de los simples
demonios oprimidos pero ciertamente no
son la mayoría de los pacientes en
ninguno de los estudios publicados y no
es datos de que las embarazadas o los
chicos un virus agresivo eso quiere
decir que algo distinto le pasa a los
ancianos que hace que tengan el problema
nosotros esto está por verse creemos que
lo que les pasa es que durante la vida
uno va juntando un montón de memoria en
el sistema inmune y esa memoria como que
en los ancianos se va
no mucho a las cosas que vivieron desde
el principio de la vida pero no a las
que vienen ahora entonces ahí hay un
choque entre un sistema inmune que no
termina entender qué es lo que está
pasando y el virus y algunas personas
eso les pasa independiente de su estado
de salud general claro está que ese
choque en el contexto de admitir
problemas de corazón y problemas de
pulmón mucho que más pequeñito puede
hacer mucho daño pero igual toda persona
mayor de 65 años tendrán los ojos
abiertos y cuidarse porque bien tiene
una chance menor que la que se dice de
tener problemas si los tienes los tienes
claro
y quiero hablar de que podemos hacer y
hay dos niveles de estrés el nivel
individual o en el grupo íntimo que uno
tiene y otro es a nivel sociedad
a nivel sociedad empezó a ver varios
anuncios desde que en china acercaron a
toda una región y 260 millones de
personas que no podían salir de sus
casas sustancialmente y con eso lograron
como decías antes revertir la tendencia
y ahora está en picada en caída
a situaciones en los cuales italia
empezó de a poquito una ciudad a una
región ahora todo el país primero que la
gente no sabía la casa ahora cerrando
los negocios a eeuu que al principio no
hizo mucho y ahora empezó a tomar
algunas medidas como que no lleguen
vuelos desde europa a eeuu en américa
latina hubo distintos casos que se
fueron haciendo que más o menos
rápidamente cuál cuál es la mejor
estrategia para una sociedad o sea
poniéndote en el rol de un decisora de
una sociedad como como abordase este
desafío bueno por un lado yo no quiero
imaginar el peso que tiene en el espalda
los decisores cómo se van a dormir todos
los días lo difícil que debe ser la
situación para los ministros de salud
para la gente que está tomando las
decisiones dicho esto y yo creo que lo
que tenemos como oportunidad en la
argentina ahora ya tenemos o la teníamos
pero estamos al borde en esta situación
es de aprender de qué hizo cada país y
utilizar las enseñanzas de los países
para no repetir errores yo creo que no
sería el consuelo que le pasó lo mismo a
italia o españa
a esta altura la estructura quisiéramos
decir que nos va a pasar lo que le pasa
a alemania o lo que le pasa a holanda a
estos países que tienen pocos hasta hoy
- - víctimas fatales en esa decisión
obviamente también hay un montón de
perspectivas hay una perspectiva
sanitaria neta pura y dura digamos que
hacemos bueno si uno pudiera tener todo
el mundo aislado uno por uno y haría que
el virus desaparezca de la faz de la
tierra pero siendo realista las
consecuencias son en salud en lo que la
sociedad está dispuesta a aceptar y hay
consecuencias políticas económicas el
golpe económico de esto yo no lo quiero
porque no entiendo nada pero intuyo que
va a ser fenomenal guancha las bolsas
cayeron 30 por ciento en los últimos
días y la gente va a estar escuchando
dentro de dos o tres días esto se va a
reír de lo que estoy diciendo ahora
bueno se si va si va a ser mucho peor o
no
y está bien de quedarnos en nuestras
casas pero la gente tiene que trabajar y
si se empiezan a romper las cadenas de
producción de abastecimiento nos vamos a
hablar sin comida en algún momento bueno
justamente ahí aparecen todos estos
problemas que plantea la pandemia que
son ajenos a la enfermedad específica
pero también es cierto que eso va a
suceder igualmente si nos infecta mos
todos o sea si esto entra correr por
todos lados dentro de tres días tenemos
diez mil cien mil infectados vamos a
entrar a las casas van a cerrar las
puertas porque no hay otras situaciones
que posible políticamente no hay nada
más que se puede hacer entonces la
pregunta es cuando la planta es cuando
en ese sentido cuando en las escuelas y
la verdad es que es muy fácil tomar una
posición y ser muy crítico pero también
es muy difícil tomar esas decisiones
porque nadie sabe cuál funciona porque
es la primera vez entonces hay visiones
más conservadoras hay visiones más
agresivas y más proactivas
eeuu para mí es un disparate hubo mucha
presión
yo creo inclusive a nivel central para
cómo minimizar lo que estaba pasando
prestado su gestión y fractura sanitaria
que no sólo tenemos eeuu tienen no
solamente tiene mucho equipamiento tiene
mucha gente que no sabe manejar tiene
una estructura que es muy distinta
entonces está preparado para lidiar con
cosas que nosotros en algunos lugares
probablemente no podamos manejar de la
misma manera entonces la decisión es la
mía pero evidentemente todo lo que pueda
aplanar la curva yo creo que es deseable
para que sea plan en la curva sin
enfermos o con menos enfermos y que no
se aplane la curva una vez que haya
muchos infectados y ya no queden bien
infectadas por una de las críticas que
escuchen mucho en estos días es que
estamos hablando de esto parece que no
hay otro tema de conversación de repente
es lo único de lo que conversamos pero
hay otras cosas que nos matan mucho más
que esto de las cuales no conversamos en
particular en enfermedades el dengue el
sarampión entiendo que los datos son
bastante más abrumadores o en accidente
de tránsito
en el cual en argentina solamente mueran
en promedio 22 personas por día en
accidente de tránsito si realmente
merece la atención que le estamos dando
a nuestros pues yo creo que es imposible
evaluarlo como otra factor más de riesgo
si fuese así vamos a suponer que china
no hubiera detectado este coronario lo
que hubiera sucedido hace 15 años y el
gobierno lo hubiera mantenido en
silencio pero hubiera habido gente que
entró a china que tampoco pasaba y se lo
hubiera llevado a otros lados pero no
supiéramos que existe pues estaríamos
diciendo es un mal año de gripe estaría
enterrado en estadísticas algo pasó en
el norte de italia no se sabe muy bien
que lo cierto es que ahora sabemos si la
información genera toda esta locura
también y esta desesperación y en algún
lugar siempre está el pensamiento
egoísta de cada individuo y lo tengo yo
no lo tengo yo no tiene mis hijos lo
tienen mis padres y allí está toda la
angustia que está encerrada alrededor
pero lo que nos decís es absolutamente
cierto te cuento un ejemplo que bien
paradigmático nosotros hicimos un
trabajo en el año 2009 con la pandemia
de gripe de un millón 300 mil chicos que
seguimos en el conurbano bonaerense y
mostramos que se habían muerto 13 chicos
de gripe pandémica ese año el año
anterior en la gripe común de 2008 se ha
muerto un chico entonces dijimos bueno
se murió en 13 se había muerto uno
había medios que titulaban se multiplicó
por 13 la mortalidad ese mismo año en
una población mucho más chiquita pero te
diría más 100 veces más chiquita casi
que nosotros seguimos rutinariamente se
murieron 25 chicos de bronquiolitis
nadie le llamó la atención no hizo el
ruido que hizo yo creo que también
porque la gente dice bueno hay una
serpiente no me va a picar se muere
150.000 personas por año por picaduras
serpiente a mí al cien que tras los yo
me cuido cuando manejo está la sensación
es que no la controlas que te puede
agarrar de voleo y ahí está medio
también la desesperación que hacemos
individualmente para cuidarlos bueno
primero creerlo no creérsela yo lo que
crear que esto está pasando porque yo
encontré eso yo tengo para mí han sido
días infernales yo estoy todo el día con
el teléfono todo el tiempo todo el
tiempo el whatsapp y muchas veces yo
digo no mira yo haría esto yo este lugar
hoy los seis no sé vamos a poner un
lugar específico sólo cerraría hoy
espera dos semanas bueno pero no pasa
nada no hay nadie enfermo si no hay
nadie enfermo porque los enfermos van a
aparecer entre diez días pero si vos
haces hoy esta reunión dentro de diez
días más todavía tienes el conteo
andando para los de hoy entonces sé
consciente de que esto es un muy mal
ejemplo el que voy a dar el que lo digo
pues te reunió con bocio listo en otro
no lo diría
las radiaciones hacen la radiación la
adquirí sin saber qué está pasando y te
enteras después este te lo llevas
puesto antes es mucho más benigno a la
mayoría no le hace nada pero lo que yo
quiero es dar el concepto de que uno no
está enterado inmediatamente um estamos
todo bien acá no pasa nada hoy no pasa
nada y lo lógico es que aunque pase
vamos a estar casi todos bien pero le
vamos a dar una dimensión completamente
fina que la que podríamos darle si
pensáramos que hoy no sabemos entonces
todos quietos supongamos que me enfermo
que contradijo el virus el coronavirus
que hago te quedas en tu casa llamas al
médico
el sas que te sentís mal te van a
testear lo ideal es que los vestidos
ocurran eventualmente todos ambulatorios
si estás bien te quedas en tu casa y te
pasar 10 días viendo televisión y más o
menos en dos semanas se te acabará la
charla estés mejor
pones la radio de radio la uso todavía
pero pero pero te quedas quieto en tu
casa y sabes que el 999 mil personas
esto no mata y que probablemente en 900
y muchas ni siquiera te lleve al
sanatorio eso es lo que tendría la
cabeza apartas al resto familia y te
aguantas la ansiedad porque es quien no
se va a poner ansioso pero la verdad es
que suena si a injustificada porque si
lo piensas en frío vos jerry en tu casa
tuviste gripe por ahí como 50 en el
ministeio la entonces es muy parecida y
también una cosa recontra importante
pensar en tus padres estos tíos todos
los que estén que nos deben acercar
de encontrarlo porque a ellos sí que se
le juega otra parte y entiendo que esto
es bastante contagioso en el sentido de
que no es como en una una gripe que uno
se tapa un poquito y evita el contagio
acá la forma de transmisión puede
persistir en los lugares y toca
superficies o cómo se contagia estoy
bien qué hacer para cuidarnos la verdad
es ésta hay mucho miedo entonces hay
mucho reporte y todo reporte se
sobredimensiona entonces desde un punto
de vista de si yo estuviera ajeno a los
datos generales te diría no no es muy
contagioso porque los datos que dan es
23 personas infectadas gente infectada
porque estuvo mucho tiempo en contacto
con otro infectado pero íntimo y en la
persona previo 100 personas más que no
se infectaron o sea que no está
enteramente claro lo que para mí sugiere
que esto es bastante infeccioso
realmente es lo que hablábamos de la
situación italiana en italia yo creo que
esto no lo conté hubo ocho personas que
vinieron a argentina entre italia españa
hace una semana que se habían infectado
del virus y cada una vino en forma
independiente no vinieron todos juntos
de manera tal que no tuviera una
oportunidad contagiarse unos a otros los
tipos vinieron y se le engancharon allá
en el momento en que ellos llegaron a la
argentina italia reportaba 3.000
infectados y españa- reportaba 200 y
pico esas son cifras oficiales cifras
oficiales se decía tenemos 3.200
personas entre los 70 millones italianos
y los 45 millones pañoles están
infectados uno diría si un argentino se
va de turista a italia o españa las
chance cosas con los 2.000 efectivos que
encima están en la casa solamente hay
muchos más infectados que se nos 100
pero está bien porque era lo que decía
que él porque ahí está claro hay muchos
más infectados los que decimos que hay
porque tardan en reconocer que están
infectados porque el sistema si alguno
tiene la infraestructura en ningún lugar
del mundo lo hizo en korea y corella por
eso yo siempre insisto que es un lugar
que hay que mirar para identificar a los
que tienen el virus pero no les pasa
nada que es lo que tenga una una
realidad que te puede pasar a vos como
individuo y le dice al gobierno bueno
cuál es la situación general
italia no pudo hacer eso no estaba
preparado para hacer eso entonces italia
se quedó con los graves que eran los que
venían a los hospitales y había que
no tenía tiempo de las enfermeras bueno
hoy dejemos la terapia intensiva nos
vamos a ir por el barrio vamos a ponerle
un hisopo la nariz a todas las personas
para ver quién lo tiene al no tener esa
información se magnifica la gravedad
porque vos estás con la lupa digamos
delante del desastre te voy a dar un
ejemplo bien concreto cuando empezó la
pandemia de gripe el 2009 yo trabajo en
gripe pensaba bueno no pasa tanto no
pasa tanto el programa mi clínico me
dice no sabes se murieron dos tipos en
la guardia es que hablando año 2009 en
la ciudad argentina o en algún lugar
estos importantes de buenos aires yo me
asusté hablé con un par de personas y
agarramos el auto con roaming con rommel
hipster y con otra persona a trabajar
con nosotros y nos fuimos al hospital
malvinas argentinas que era el centro de
referencia para pacientes graves de
pandemia durante la pandemia de gripe
del 2009 entramos al hospital que estaba
vacío absoluta en el vacío nos pusieron
las escafandras que parecíamos astronaut
tercera película ciencia ficción y
porque tiene características la gripe
pandémica muy distintas al korona virus
pandémico lo que encontramos es montones
de personas entre 3
y cincuenta y pico de años moribundas en
respiradores una situación espantosa
ahí estábamos en primer plano era el
embudo que traía todos los enfermos
entonces cuando yo salí de ahí no podía
comer no podía o sea afuera estaba lo
más bien no tenían la menor idea de que
pasaba una cosa así ahora si uno está
parado adentro todo el día creo que eso
es todos lados entonces ese es el
problema de las lentes en esto no
cualquier cosa si uno está dentro de la
cancha de boca en pleno partido y no
sabe que existe resta la argentina diría
bulos al genio son todos fanáticos tanto
gritando todo el tiempo bueno salida que
realmente no es ese fenómeno el que
permanentemente distorsión esto cuando
aparece un enfermero desesperado que
está desesperado porque donde el estado
tiene que estar desesperado claro
en un momento dijiste al pasar me
pareció entender que si vos te contagias
y te curas quedas inmunizado para
adelante eso ya se sabe que es así con
este virus
es imposible que no sea considerando lo
que pasó en wuhan no se sabe por qué
también no se puede medir pero si no se
volverían a infectar y estaría un
círculo loco
y es la característica central de los
virus yendo hacia adelante entiendo que
hoy no hay un tratamiento para estos hay
que esperar que se te cure solo pero hay
una posibilidad de usar antivirales o
algún otro tipo de medicación para que
existe que contagia si te enfermas
puedes curarte más rápido
empiezo por lo bueno y sigo por otro
vacunas y otras intervenciones están
avanzando a una velocidad sideral y eso
es herencia del big-bang del dominio en
el 2009 la vacuna de gripe había que
crecer la en huevos de gallina
fertilizados no había suficientes juegos
para crecer vacuna entonces había un
tema de supply de huevo para solucionar
el problema entonces los científicos que
esto lo hace normales de los americanos
y los europeos de germanos más vale que
encontremos otra manera hacer vacuna
porque nos va a pasar cada tanto
encontraron otras maneras y esas maneras
de ser bah cuáles son las que permiten
que hoy se hagan vacunas de coronavirus
a toda velocidad y ya se están testeando
eso por un lado en cuanto antivirales el
problema con estas situaciones es que
cuando vos estás en la trinchera de esta
situación el tipo que está teniendo la
terapia intensiva le quiere dar todo a
todos porque es muy desesperante es un
ser humano y quiere que se salven todos
y es lo que tiene que hacer pero lo que
pasa cuando sea en esas situaciones es
que uno no sabe qué sirve a qué nos
sirve porque la mayoría la gente
sobrevive gracias a dios entonces vos y
yo y le di este remedio no se le di
jarabe de d
de azúcar y anduvieron entonces lo que
ves en los reportes de esto que yo
reviso muchos reportes que vienen del
caso en china es que por ejemplo
muchísima gente que fue tratada con
medicina tradicional china entonces yo
podría sentarme acá de siete mil a jerry
hubo diez mil tratados con medicinas
atención china le fue bárbaro una
mortalidad de 0.1 por ciento que la
mortalidad llegó diría no voy a comprar
toda la medicina tradicional afronta es
cual que hubiese pasado si no le daban
es exacta postor janis y por eso los
estudios eventuales y éstos a veces iba
a llegar a pasar pues yo creo que este
es un temporada que se va a ir
desapareciendo son los estudios en los
que la mitad recibe algo y la mitad no
recibe que se pueden hacer cuando bien
están mejores son muy difíciles de hacer
en esta situación
entiendo que es un poco distinto el tema
de antivirales porque se pueden usar
antivirales que se usaban para virus
parecidos y que quizás puedan ser
efectivos y ellos ya están aprobados
para que los médicos los prescriben no
para que los recetan si con la
incertidumbre de si son eficaces olores
feroz por el siguiente motivo esta es
una enfermedad que se pone severa a los
10 14 días nuestra enfermedad que
arranca asevera el problema de eso es
que el virus arranca el primer día y los
antivirales funcionan bien y esto no es
para coronavirus porque yo no tengo la
menor idea como funcionará en
coronavirus pero normalmente cuanto
antes empiezas a tratar un cáncer por
ejemplo en gripe la gripe suele incubar
24 horas entonces la idea es bueno bueno
detectas te lo trataste y ahí freno a
cabo tienes un virus que ya está ya hizo
living comedor y cocina entonces en tu
cuerpo entonces la pregunta es si hay
aún va a haber un error o no para los
antivirales claro
por otro mencionarte las vacunas las
vacunas entiendo que es más complicado
porque tienes que testear la gente sana
correcto y lleva más tiempo hasta saber
si se enferman o no si yo estoy en un
grupo soy internacionales de evaluación
desde las vacunas que vienen para tratar
de contribuir con sugerencias con guías
con cosas y es impresionante hoy yo me
pasé toda la mañana en esto y son grupos
podemos atrás a todos los científicos
tope sentados a la mesa pensando a la
vez tratando de encontrar la manera sea
lo más rápido posible lo más seguro
posible y eso va a pasar quizás va a
pasar cuando esto ya haya pasado de
largo pero para lastimar al agro que
viene
cuáles son los escenarios de que puede
pasar de acá a un mes a seis meses o un
año no hay mucha incertidumbre en la
gente que está dejando de ir al trabajo
trabaja desde la casa o cancelando
reuniones o eventos
viajes viajes definitivamente
qué pasa entre un mes dentro de seis
meses entre un año bueno vamos a ir así
si volvemos a grabar la semana que viene
práctico cualquier otra cosa porque
todos estamos aprendiendo hoy 12-13 en
marzo en un mes vamos a estar adentro de
esto en seis meses ya no y lo más
probable es que transitemos de alguna
manera dios quiera como los países que
transitaron más leves que haya una única
víctima fatal como hubo muy poquito
esperemos eso decíamos eso cuanto más
estrictos seamos en el cumplimiento de
las normas y cuanto más nos cuidemos más
chances tenemos de que eso ocurra el año
que viene yo sospecho que barba cuna
entonces yo creo que una vez que haya
una vacuna va a ver dos fenómenos
interesantes hay un abarth mucha gente
se hace vacunarse y va a ver mucho menos
antivacunas que los que cuando la lengua
se vea y el antigua kun es un lujo de
clase media nadies antigua pone en el
medio del sahara
en el medio y áfrica cuando tenéis el
sarampión golpeando de la puerta
y esto que dice que hay que actuar
rápido ahí hay un tema un miedo a
sobrerreaccionar
están los dos riesgos el riesgo de
reaccionar de menos y reaccionar de más
yo no tengo miedo a sobrerreaccionar y
esto que te digo es me hago cargo de lo
que yo digo y soy consciente que yo no
tomo las decisiones pero cuando yo
discuto con alguien que me dice bueno no
sé tengo un montón de ancianos que
vienen a ver lo que yo hago y se van a
quedar sin programa bueno 15 días vamos
15 días veamos qué pasa en ese día si en
15 días no pasó nada todo el mundo
vuelve a lo normal en 15 días pasó algo
vamos a agradecer haber parado quince
días antes yo creo que no hay decisiones
no es definitivo no nos vamos a tirar de
un edificio de manera tal que se pueden
tomar medidas con cierto margen de
tiempo a mí no me dan miedo yo
preferiría que digan de mí que sobre
reacciones cuando yo que consejo un
amigo y me llaman te imaginas todo día
en general optó por las cosas más más
fuertes y no sé si tengo razones porque
seguro que esas cosas en la calle es
este tipo está loco es posible pero la
manera que lo pienso yo prefiero que
después me venga y me diga que estoy
loco y yo soy bueno tengo muchos amigos
en común yo sabes que a mí me llama
mucha gente para que la tranquilice y
mira me salió un pelo blanco no es nada
tranquilo
esta versión agua es yoigo bueno sí
probablemente nada pero yo me lo tomaría
en serio no pero yo me cuidaría yo no
iría lo de mi papá que tiene 88 años yo
evitaría que mi papá vaya mi papá va al
gimnasio tres veces por semana elige no
vas más al gimnasia obra porque es
verdad que el 90% de casos no pasa nada
pero si te toca el dado te tocan acá no
hay nada que hacer si te toca eso es lo
que es importante saber hay una enología
que se me ocurrió la noche pensando en
la conversación que íbamos a tener y es
la analogía con los terremotos
viste que en california siempre hablan
de que viene el big one el grande que
los va a destruir del todo y cada vez
que hay un pequeño temblor tienen miedo
de que sea que esté llegando el porque
saben que se está acumulando tensión y
tarde o temprano va haber un terremoto
grande esperemos que sea más tarde que
temprano pero nadie sabe acá vos dijiste
que esta es una enfermedad que tiene
ciertas complejidades porque no estamos
cuando tenemos inmunidad porque nos va a
agarrar a un montón de nosotros pero no
es tan severa como podría haber sido y
no no tiene la combinación terrible de
ser de tener un periodo largo de
incubación contagiosa y mucha mortandad
después que podría ser un nivel nuevo la
convención hacemos con mucho periodo
incubación ese sería un posible big one
en temas de epidemias de pandemias es
una cuestión de tiempo hasta que nos
llegue una acción o no estoy seguro
sabes yo creo que
es exactamente como decirse ésta es una
enfermedad leve que por números
generamos muchos números mucha gente
dañada pero no por la enfermedad
individual de cada persona
que es preocupante para la gente muy
mayor sobre todo que los demás por esto
yo te contaba del fenómeno inmunológico
es muy probable que la pasen como una
gripe común o como un resfrío común pero
también es cierto que nosotros damos
vueltas hace mucho el hombre de vueltas
hace 6 millones de años entonces hace
mucho tiempo que no hay una de estas
vidas y la oportunidad de que haya un
'big one' es permanente los mercados de
animales salvajes sencillas funcionan
todos los días ahora están parados pero
funcionaban todos los días las aves y
los cerdos están juntas en concón todos
los días hay miles de oportunidades de
que esto ocurra y por algún motivo no
ocurre el motivo no es a mi juicio
intervención divina o suerte hay una
cuestión evolutiva evidentemente que
estos gérmenes no les funciona a su
beneficio ese camino por ahí este camino
es un camino atractivo de diseminación
para mujer me en silencio me multiplicó
me dice 'me no no mató con eso sigo
porque siempre hay que pensar que aunque
no es inteligente un virus porque no lo
es está pensando con una lógica
darwiniana está pensando como
competitivamente seguir múltiple
y eso es un elemento irónicamente son
son y a la vez extraordinariamente
inteligente y poderoso bueno pero nos
sentamos a un metro y medio más o menos
que es la distancia que recomiendan que
deberíamos estar mínima porque eso como
esto se contagia mucho por las gotitas
de agua cuando respiramos poseemos
estornudamos y caen por gravedad parece
que esa es la distancia mínima así que
para todos los que nos están escuchando
mantengan la distancia cuídense cuidamos
mucho ojalá esto no sea tan fuerte como
podría ser que podamos rápidamente
doblegar la amenaza y poder seguir con
una vida más o menos normal porque la
forma en la forma en que nos impacto es
increíble no en estos días
sería bueno que pero quizás
contrariamente hace un mes que era
solamente ruido y uno decía qué locura a
todos los medios toda esta persecución
de el tema creo que hay dos balances no
uno es esos tableros que están todo el
tiempo diciendo número de casos dicen
cualquier cosa porque si nosotros
estamos de acuerdo en que la mortalidad
es uno de cada mil es imposible que en
italia haya
entonces 10.000 infectados para el amor
imposible que ver un millón de estar
mirando ese tablero uno no sabe lo que
está mirando si mañana el primer
ministro italiano dicen me testean a
todos los italianos el número va a dar
un salto y la gente va infartar él
también nos sirve para que los
epidemiólogos porque siempre están
viviendo lo mismo no porque sea la
mención correcta pueden estimar hacia
dónde van las cosas pero uno aprender
todos los días y subió un muerto no les
sirve para nada tampoco les sirven mira
las estadísticas iraníes el sistema de
salud iraní lo que puede hacer el
gobierno iraní no tiene que ver con lo
que hago que no argentino entonces sirve
saber que todo mundo está alerta para
seguir alerta pero seguirlo como si
fuera un partido de básquet desesperado
me parece le suena el minuto a minuto no
sirve no si no sea bueno gracias
esperamos que les haya gustado o servido
y que les dé herramientas para ver cómo
encarar la como enfrentamos a esta esta
pandemia esta enfermedad y que nos deje
poder salir lo mejor posible de todo
esto y volver a una vida más o menos
normal gracias
[Música]